i've been delightedly playing dune spice
wars harvesting melange and trying to
figure out how to pronounce quest
croissants how to rap doesn't matter i'm
equally ready to turn hordes of tyranids
into a jackson pollock painting in
warhammer 40k space marine 2. in this
brutal third person shooter you once
again step into the oversized power
armor of titus an elite primary space
marine in a galaxy immersed in a
never-ending war to take us further
inside the grim dark i am joined by tim
willits and oliver hollis the creative
director on warhammer 40k space marine
2. first of all thank you so much for
joining us
yes thank you thanks for having us good
to be here now tim i want to start with
you you previously worked at id software
on doom how would you say the space
marine compares to doomguy
that is a good question uh i bet many
people did not know that the original
doomguy was actually a space marine
inspired by
an even older space marine which is the
warhammer 40 000 space marine so you
know it's really exciting for for me to
work on
and space marine too you know because
it's a great franchise and i know that
it's inspired so many other video games
throughout the last 25 30 years oh oh
absolutely and there's so much lore to
sift through and i think this brings us
to talk a little bit about the new space
marine that you're gonna get to play a
primary space when oliver talk to us a
little bit about captain titus and what
makes this class of space marine
different from the others in the
universe so the space marine is is a
brainchild of the emperor uh the kind of
leader of this uh of humanity and in the
grim dark future he saw the dangers that
the universe presented and he created a
super soldier from his own dna and each
of these different factions these
different chapters have different
genetic traits of the emperor but what
makes the primaris different is that a
guy named belisarius call
the emperor's kind of chief scientist
went back did some digging in the old uh
data and found a way to enhance the the
qualities that a space marine has by
installing new devices new kind of bio
implants in their body so now these guys
are two and a half meter tall monsters
capable of destroying anything in their
path it's reminding me of the thousand
times i have re-watched the astartes
animation it's amazing so exciting it's
so exciting that we now get to be in
that position to play that kind of
character and in the trailer we saw a
lot of tyranids are they the main enemy
that you're going to be against if so
what makes them such a compelling foe in
this particular game the tyranids are
the main focus and what makes them
compelling is that they are extra
galactic uh locust like creatures they
they've come in from goodness knows
where they spread like wildfire they
devour everything in their path and they
leave nothing in their wake so one of
the great things about the tyranids is
they come in the thousands
and our proprietary engine the saber
swarm engine can can deliver these epic
battles now we will have thousands of
tyranids and you will rip and tear
through them all i mean that is so
thrilling because this is the sort of
thing that older games couldn't even
hope to do and you're talking a little
bit about combat i know that some of the
previous entries were more melee focused
what's the combat like in space marine 2
so the combat in space marine 2 is a mix
of in-your-face melee combat along with
some really cool over-the-top weapons so
um you know we we we looked at you know
the original space marine game where
they where it had a lot of this push
forward combat which has inspired many
other video games but uh with that never
stop never take cover combat is integral
to space marine too along with you know
these these really cool powerful weapons
so you're either tearing up
enemies in front of you or you're
blowing them away from the back of the
battlefield it's uh it's it's the best
of both worlds i mean that sounds so
terrific and i mean i know you guys are
huge fans of the 40k lore so i'm curious
about in working on this project what's
been the most fun seeing come together
and what's saber interactive focusing on
right now right at the beginning of the
project tim and i went to the warhammer
museum which was an incredible
experience and you go around all these
cabinets where these incredible
miniatures that have been painted by
these masters are arranged in these
dioramas you find yourself kind of
crouching down and looking into the
ranks of space marines that are facing
tyranids or orcs or whatever and
something that tim and i said at that
moment was we need to make this come
alive i don't want to look at this i
want to be inside this i want to be
gunning down tyranids by the thousands
and so
seeing that actually happen and come
alive has been thrilling am i going to
feel like the characters in the astartes
animation because if so then i'm buying
the game immediately
even more so when you're wielding one of
those massive weapons and you're faced
with a thousand tyranids who want to eat
you alive and you're just letting rip
and you can see shell casings bursting
out of these massive weapons one after
another the sound the gameplay the way
it feels is all designed to make you
feel like the most powerful warrior in
the universe well perfect that answers
everything thank you so much tim and
oliver from saber interactive for
joining us i can't wait warhammer 40k
space marine 2 comes to pc ps5 xbox
series x and s soon now next